he might he might do it for the content but
for content he might do it for the content
he's thinking about doing it for the
content he's not thinking how to mate here
do it for the content
speaking of being the best space possible i think
the games are starting in fact looks like they
have and we're off to see the wizard with a french
and we did look at this full disclosure because
benji for the record has pretty much only played
a french in in his uh in his chess career and so
rayne and i spent some time just looking at the
basics of the advanced variation no trickery
and you're going to see that on the board the
craziest thing about benji is that he's had his
chess.com account since 2018. in january of
this year january 10th his rapid rating was
817. he has gained 545 points he is currently
at his peak which he hit yesterday so this kid
and that's insane danny so i think um the
question will be interesting as to whether
benji understands this a5 idea have him and
hammer talked about that that's a key point
in undermining the front structure did they
not get around to that because they didn't
necessarily expect a3 i think that's going to be
a key thing in this position and we see he kind
of doesn't and he's actually blundered the d5 pawn
so this is not working out well for benji no it's
not and uh okay i mean the truth is that
after knight takes d5 e7 is still protected
so computer is giving like plus four or
something completely ridiculous because
it's got a very kind of methodical way now to
pick apart everything and win but reigns gotta see
through everything like he's gotta realize that
taking on e7 is good and then he's got to realize
like the next step it's not just winning a pawn is
that black's position is gonna crumble right but
gonna get spicy yeah this is the oh okay see
the problem well you know that's a great move
uh but benji's gotta find bishop d5 like it's
a great move unless you've played bishop d5
you gotta plug the square right yeah good point
because yeah go ahead sorry i was gonna say bishop
yeah bishop f7 e6 d5 i mean black resigns black
forget black stops playing the french defense
after super f7 so i did tell i did tell rain
that i said my main goal is for you to get hammer
to feel like he needs to switch his students
openings like that's the main goal and he's
like who's hammer like don't worry
about it yeah that i always wonder
you know in these events like how many
of these creators know each other like
not even by name you know just by content all this
stuff because they're they're all over they're all
working you know maybe even hundreds of hours in
a seven day week i'm just curious like you know
do people listen to logic's music but put that you
know and then like you know do they watch mr b's
videos there's so many different people across
so many different uh kind of categories but you
know back to the chess uh this is uh looking like
your guy is going to win the game because falling
apart anyway rain rain is definitely cleaning up
here so tough lesson for benji i think that um
rayne again didn't get what we looked
at but the the goal i took as a coach
paid off because i was like look man always
what happens here is most the time you look
at these specific x's and o's he plays a move
order one of you forgets it focus on the forest
through the trees what are you doing here
and that's really legit is my mindset and i
think it's partly because you just have
had i've had so many experiences where
when you try to go the other way and buckle down
and say this is the exact trap the amount of
times you get what happened between charlie and
xqc levy is like one in a million right it just
never works out that way so you should focus on
your bigger chess goals rather than trying to trap
people all right i'll get off my soapbox about
coaching all right here we go shout out to the
uh the community and the viewership we're growing
here the day's just getting started very good okay
this is an awesome battery set up by benji and
again this is the what you would love to see
that is that is the most tight rope walking way
to stop that mate danny you took the words out of
my mind i was about to say what you'd love to see
what you'd love to see right bishop c3 is the move
that's like dude solve the problem yeah i mean
like g3 we don't even we go to break like we don't
even okay just like there's room d8 the rook is
gone no more background problems if frank wilson
hangs back ranked mate i'll i don't know i'll
give like 500. oh my god that movie just played
i wasn't expecting it my calves my calf muscles
tightened i don't even have calf muscles danny
i go for a two-minute walk and i get how do you
still work out in quarantine you still work dude
i'm obsessed with crossfit it's my only therapy um
but the gym i go to totally socially distance and
safe what is going on here um everyone gets their
own box and it's like it's it's away from other
people it's very very cleanly we have to wipe
down all the weights when we're done it's actually
kind of gross the amount of uh clorox that goes
into keeping that place covered free i might be
getting sick because of that but that's a whole
another story queen city now rook d7 right rain's
done messing around i mean rain is uh he sees rook
d7 we're shipping it or queen d7 but yeah rook d7
man rain just no back rank yeah there it is all
right he smoked this one that's he really did
that was that was actually stunning sometimes
you can't measure that players of all levels
blunder but certainly we know that there's a lot
of blunders in pogchamps um but the fact that he
when he wins he just cleans up and the fact that
he um oh speaking of he plays better when he
yeah that that really was brutal that's not quite
a game that will make you quit the french defense
but it will definitely make you reconsider
what to play against the advance french
uh because yeah that that that game if anything
anybody in the chat who plays e4 and struggles
with the french that was a game to watch right
there that was that was very convincing great
okay so this is not quite what we looked at
this is already a transposition note that
benji played knight f3 d5 and d4 so we are
we are rayne is on his own i absolve myself
of all influence over the game but i did tell
him this that if we get a queen spawn okay he
remembered that that's awesome you got to
make sure in a queens pawn game everybody
that you can take back with a pawn because you've
got to keep that structure together you don't want
things like this to happen or your opponent has
two pawns in the center you don't this is actually
theory but we're not going to get into that the
point is positionally you've really got to protect
so i'm glad to see rain remember that principle he
will probably play g6 here nope he didn't g6 and
bishop back is is kind of what he's familiar with
king's indian stuff so here we go we'll see benji
is really good at these positions he likes b3
bishop b2 slow development and then later expand
with e4 he's in his wheelhouse so okay and as i
say that he plays that move so i think this shows
he has the plan that you're talking about living
he's aware that he needs to strive for e4 i'm with
you he needs to complete development first benji
you got to develop and maybe even put rooks in
the center first don't don't be in a rush to play
e4 um right but i think he has that idea in mind
well i think bishop d3 was a really important
loss of tempo because yeah like there was no
need to go bishop d3 he should have just and
now right now if reign plays e5 man this is
no you're right actually that's right
bad or positive i'm officially rooting
for benji in this game we want overtime
we want free chips we want pizza too
i would love some pizza i had pizza last night
at 2 a.m that's why i love new york city yeah
that's why i'm also gaining too much weight but
it was it was amazing man pepperoni right out
there right out the oven oh so good oh my god
rain rain's in his own today i can feel it yeah
you've seen the board well e5 is a great move such
a problem is that you don't you didn't need to
make that move your bishop was not really changing
too much you know what the computer is suggesting
here c5 by black which just looks like a mouse
that's the best move and then it wants knight a4
and that's why your valve bar is so deceiving get
ready for this eval bar to go nuts everybody
because i don't think see and here you go rain
plays queen e7 as much as we were plotting e5
and i think it was rightfully so i think rain
is seeing the board well and he clearly saw
this idea but the truth is it may have been a
little bit of a too advanced follow-up because
now now he's going to get himself in trouble
yeah d takes c6 now benji's got to get that
tunnel vision i benji's got to realize e4
is not a threat which i think is why he played
bishop d3 he was so worried about the e4 square
but there's no threat like right you're fine just
take the pawn on c6 probably don't take twice
because the rook will come to c8 and hit the
knight and maybe it works i haven't done fulham
here and actually you know calculated but now
rain is now rain is going off the deep end here
oh man rain's gone wild i think they both have
just miscalculated the pieces on that square
rain is avoiding trades which this is a this
is a good idea i think conceptually when you're
like i'm losing i need to keep the pieces
on the board but rook cd8 is actually a big
mistake if benji sees bishop a3 because this
rook here is running out of squares um oh it
looks like benji has played a5 and knight b5 so
that was that was a missed opportunity from benji
bishop a3 would have been pretty nice and that's
what the computer liked um rook c6 now probably
just to tag the queen but yeah white is still
better well rain is keeping this close benji
now at two minutes and 20 seconds but if the a5
pawn falls there it goes yeah this is still still
anyone's game and actually remember all rain needs
is a draw to punch his ticket to the championship
so we are all rooting for benji we want overtime
here but but the advantage has slipped away where
oh i don't like that oh i don't like that huge
mistake knight h5 knight h5 or any knight move
this is not a move that rain uh wants to play
that is terribly weakening to his king side
oh knight h5 just sneak in oh man the thing that
is a minute h5 is now you've got back rank threats
um yeah g7 is covered oh that's two wrong
way that's too sober of a move you need to
get weird with it i almost wonder if benji's
just a little i don't want to say intimidating
he's a little nervous right i feel like he knows
reign is the strongest player he's faced yet
and he's not playing as aggressive as we saw him
clean up some of the other matches he had right
i mean i feel like he's playing a little timid
here was that a slip or does he want to play a5
rook b8 there was really good but okay rook 8 is
fine as well yeah yeah this is surgical now will
rain realize he can trade queens and push the pawn
it's actually his best move even though ironically
okay and he does it doesn't ironically he
takes and here comes a5 and now if you're benji
oh no he doesn't know a5 e4 just go e45 oh wrong
pawn neither player is using their pawn advantage
use your pawn advantage or king g4 now wrong way
okay i think king of five and veggie wins the
game he played it i think benji is going to win
this game and we're going to have overtime kids
does rain find rook a5 only move so
that if king g5 i guess at least wow
oh my gosh reigns gonna save
it same way he did with charlie
crazy i thought there's nothing i mean the pawn
is just yeah now king e5 now black is winning no
oh no wow oh no oh my gosh brain's
winning the king of pawn ending
it's unbelievable benji can do only benji can
only draw oh it's a draw now yeah but it's
it doesn't it's over i know oh i know he's
gonna say joshua chamberlain strikes again
it's uh yeah he was winning and then he had
to actually you know it's never too late but
i think rain doesn't really care because yeah
obviously he can't win just with the king so
oh man the cinderella story man like
winning the group the only man to have
beaten start ocean i hit the head but
we're not gonna get to see the rematch
yeah it's funny because benji's probably a
tougher matchup for sardoche i don't know
how well rain will handle litz against sardoche
but um if it goes to an overtime tiebreaker but
wow what a heartbreaker for benji he was totally
winning in game two not what you saw coming
king a6 king c6 maybe 16.6 is the recipe
you need they'll mate stephen it is he
might he might do it for the content but
for content he might do it for the content
he's thinking about doing it for the
content he's not thinking how to mate here
do it for the content rain
eclipse can only be a minute long oh queen c6
i really should learn how to do that end game
no i mean i still won
uh i should have been able
to to meet you there i just
i should have taken my time wow what a game jeez
benji starting with you i know this didn't go the
way you you wanted it to today but a super close
match and uh what were your thoughts on on where
it got away from you or any of your takeaways
from this um i don't know i think i don't think
it was no i mean the first game i just made a
stupid blunder and i rained played really good i
couldn't it was really hard for me to come back um
in the second game uh i was winning and then the
time pressure just got to me and i yeah started
panicking a bit um that was basically it for me
but rain played played really good first game was
about as solid as game as i've played in a long
time and i felt really good about that and he
blundered and gave up his bishop there and then
kind of got on the ropes and had pieces forked so
i did get a little lucky there but it was a solid
game and the second game um i don't know he had um
it was something i just wasn't used to that
uh the way the center was locked up and
it's one of those things you have to be like
how much pressure is on each pawn like i've
got a knight on the pawn and a bishop on a
pawn and a queen on a pawn and i've got this
pawn on the pawn and and i just lost track of of
that and in my head i saw this fork i was like
oh there's a fork with the queen and the bishop
and but i didn't even have the fork it wasn't
even real because his knight was there so
i don't know what i was thinking but i just
my brain just kind of shut down in that little
middle part of the game in the in the second
game and then um and then and then i'm like listen
he's up three points um uh i think i play a little
faster than he does so let me just hang in there
solid as long as i can and maybe pawn by pawn claw
my way up back which i did for a large chunk of
it and then he got a really good end game strategy
and if he had rammed those pawns down my king's
throat i would have been dead as a doornail but um
i got lucky because of the time pressure as well
and then at the end danny you never taught me
how to mate with a king and a queen against the
cage i knew you were going to blame me for that
that's what you teach five-year-olds when they're
learning chess and i don't so it's danny's fault
you